تبدو هذه الاجواء هادئه نظريا لكنها
مشحونه بالتوتر مع كل حركه على الجانب
الاخر توتر قد ينفجر بمواجهه تعكر هدوء
المحيط الهادئ باكمله
الولايات المتحده وفي اخر توجهاتها
السياسيه بشان الجزيره التايوانيه وافقت
على تزويد الاخيره بصفقه اسلحه نوعيه امر
اغضب بيكين واعتبرته انتهاكا للالتزامات
السياسيه بين الجانبين
الصفقه الجديده بقيمه 619 مليون دولار
تضمنت صواريخ لمقاتلات اف 16 و200 صاروخ
جو جو متوسط المدى مضاد للطائرات اضافه
لمئه صاروخ من طراز بيهارم 88
وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه قالت ان الصفقه
الجديده ستساهم في قدره تايوان على الدفاع
عن مجالها الجوي والامن الاقليمي لترد
الصين بانها ستتعامل مع الامر بقوه وحزم
ستواصل الصين اتخاذ اجراءات حازمه وقويه
لدفاع بحزم عن سيادتها ومصالحها الامنيه
واود ان اؤكد ان تايوان جزء لا يتجزا من
اراضي الصين
الدفاع التايوانيه قالت ان الصواريخ
ستساعد في الدفاع الفعال عن مجالها الجوي
والتعامل مع ما وصفته بتهديدات واستفزازات
الجيش الصيني وذلك عقب توغل واسع النطاق
للقوات الجويه الصينيه في اجواء تايوان
باحدى وعشرين طائره خلال الاربع والعشرين
ساعه الماضيه فقط
وبين اصرار واشنطن على دعم الجزيره
التايوانيه واسرار بيكين على ضمها يبقى
التوتر سيد الموقف ومخاوف من مواجهه قد
تقلب اجواء الهادئ والعلم الذي لم يتعاف
بعد من اثار حرب اوكرانيا